I'm here with dating coach
and life game-changer, Damona Hoffman.
We're also here with two single ladies
looking for love in the digital space
and when we say two ladies,
I think we mean so many people on this planet.
And before the break, Amy gave us the scoop
on what digital dating is like in your 40s
and now it's time to hear from Allison
who's representing daters in their 20s.
Allison, what is it like for you?
Dating is really confusing in your 20s.
I have friends who are engaged
and I also have friends who are at the bars till 4:00 AM.
And I feel like I do not know where I settle into that mix.
I'm really looking for a relationship.
I really want to be in love, I'm a romantic,
I'm a cancer, if you guys are into Zodiac signs at all.
So, I really am craving that
but I feel like everyone that I'm matching with
is looking for one thing, if you catch my drift,
and it's not something that I'm really interested in.
So, I'm kind of having a hard time with that.
Damona, I love the spectrum:
friends out till 4:00 AM; other friends engaged.
What does she ask herself to find where her needle lands?
Well, she has to figure out what's comfortable for her.
And I would say, Allison,
you need to also do a little work around
who you're looking for,
figuring out what that perfect person would be
and maybe where that perfect person might be hiding.
I think dating apps
should always be a part of your dating portfolio
and it's just the best way to expand your dating pool
but that doesn't mean that you couldn't find love
out at a bar until 4:00 AM.
It doesn't happen often.
Doesn't mean it couldn't happen for you, though.
What is your approach
with your communication in online dating?
So, I'm super passive.
I kind of just wait for the guy to take the lead.
I want to see where they're gonna take it.
Are you gonna text me at 4:00 AM saying "You up?"
or are you gonna text me "Good morning"
and be like, "Hope you have a great day",
so I kind of just let them take the lead.
I'm super picky about how I let men talk to me.
So, sometimes I can come across as that I'm not interested
or a little bit mean
but I do try to let them just take the lead
and kind of fall back a little bit.
Okay, so Allison brought some screenshots
of her online messages and dating profile
for Damona to weigh in on to see what Damona's thoughts are
'cause that's what I live for.
All right, Allison,
are you up for a little role play with me?
Let's do it.
Let's read your text message
and actually talk about what you said.
I'll be the guy.
And I'll be me.
So he said "Hey... just seen your roommate."
We won't mark him down for bad grammar.
"What are you up to tonight?"
I'll be me. "Oh, I was sleeping hahaha"
"I don't do bars"
"What a good girl you are, huh?"
"When I saw her I was hoping to see you"
Okay, what do you think you're giving off
with that text message?
It definitely does seem like passive aggressive
and that I'm not interested.
Yes, I would like to see you be a little bit more fun,
a little bit more flirty, and a little engaging.
There is something you said earlier
that kind of concerned me.
You said you were picky about how they responded to you.
So when I hear picky, I actually think two things.
I think, lack of clarity on what you want,
what you're looking for, or fear.
And sometimes it's fear of rejection,
it's fear of seeing your friends partner up
and fearing you're gonna be the last one left.
And it's easier to say I'm picky than to say I'm afraid.
That's fair.
You have to be able to flirt now over text
and bring that confidence.
The next time I want you to turn up the heat a little bit.
I love that, thank you.
Do you think you have fear?
I definitely think I have fear.
I know I'm only 24
but I've definitely dealt with a lot of heartache
in my dating life and also in my personal life.
My mom actually just passed away in June,
so that was definitely like a personal heartache
that I'm dealing with and I feel like when you're grieving,
especially like going through dating,
it's kind of a little bit tricky
'cause you don't want to get hurt again.
You're already healing something separately and it's like,
I don't necessarily want to get hurt
in this realm of my life.
So, I definitely feel like I'm a little bit fearful.
First of all, I'm so sorry for your loss.
I really am.
And when we are going through something,
how do we communicate that in the romantic world?
Well, we have different seasons in our life.
So, this might not be the right season
for dating for Allison right now
but in terms of when you're communicating with dates,
I like to think of it
as people need to earn information from you.
And so, your story is not everybody's business.
So, you know, that's a very personal thing that you shared.
That might be something
that you wouldn't reveal on a first date
but only when you trust someone
and know that they can hold your feelings
and hold what you tell them in confidence as well.
And listen, you're in marketing, right?
Yes, I work in PR, yes.
Well, you better start doing some PR for yourself.
I better market myself.
You're right, Drew.
And you are a content writer.
Yes.
Well, then, you should be writing your very best, right?
Out on these apps that are true to you.
But if you're a writer for a living,
I know you got the goods.
I do, yeah, no, I can totally write a profile.
Maybe we can get together
and we can help each other with that.
Yeah, I can market you, you could write me a love story.
Done and done.
(audience clapping)
Well, thank you Amy and Allison.
And as always, Damona,
you contextualize what we are really navigating in life
and every time we talk,
I'm a smarter, wiser person.
Ah, thank you.
(upbeat music)